Daigoka no kanji no shoukai wo shimasu.
Ee daigoka de wa, ee, kou itta jyuuyon no
kanji wo shoukai shimasu.
Mazu, saishou no kanji desu keredomo, ee kono
kanji imi wa desu ne, by means of.
Ano ohanashi wa nain desu keredomo, kore itsutsu,
eeto, no five stroke desu no de, ichi, ni,
san, ee yon, go to iu sorezore eeto one stroke
desu no de kiotsukete kudasai.
De yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de i
to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
De, kore wa chotto by means of chotto kankei
nain desu keredomo, yoku, eeto more than,
than ni eeto kankei suru.
Tatoeba, ijyou, more then.
Sorekara ika, less than.
Sorekara irai, since.
Sorekara, igai, except.
Sorekara inai, within.
Kou itta tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Ee sorekara desu ne, kore wa chotto idiomatic
na hyougen nan desu keredomo, ishin denshin
to iu kotoba ga arimasu.
Kore wa tacit understanding or communication.
Ee nihon jin wa ishin denshin ga tokui desu.
Ko nani mo iwanaku demo, otagae rikai dekiru
to iu youna imi desu.
Sorekara, kunyomi de mo to iu yomikata ga
arun desukeredo mo, nani nani wo motte, by
means of to iu imi nan desu keredomo, ee,
chotto ano kore wa formal no iikata nan desu
keredomo, ma kore wo motte kaigi wo shuryou
shimasu.
We will conclude this meeting with this toka.
Ato desu ne, yoku, ano, honjitsu wo motte
taishoku shimasu, today, I will retire toka
desu ne.
Honjitsu wo motte, heiten shimasu.
Mise wo closing the store.
Konna hyougen mo arimasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee kono kanji desu keredomo imi wa merit,
sorekara success to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, kono kanji no bubun nan desu keredomo,
kochira no hidari, kono radical imi toshite
wa work toka craft no imi ga arimasu.
Soshite, kono migi gawa kore wa strength desu
yo ne.
So work with all your strength for your success,
for merit to iu imi desu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredomo, ee onyomi
de kou toka ku.
Kunyomi wa arimasen.
Tatoeba, seikou suru, kore to succeed.
Ee, seikou no hantai wa shippai desu yo ne.
Ee, kore sorekara, nenkoujyoretsu, chotto
muzukashii kotoba desu keredomo, kore wa seniority
system to iu.
Tatoeba, nihon no kaisha de wa nenkoujyoretsu
no seido wo totte imasu.
Eeto, ko itte iikata wo shimasu.
Ato, kouseki, ee kore achievement to iu kotoba
desu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji no imi desukeredo mo, imi wa
lose toka slip no imi ga arimasu.
De, kono part, kore daijoubu desu ne, kore
wa arrow no imi desu.
So, this arrow miss the target and, and kind
of you know a part kind of slipped and sticked
up to iu, ma konna oboekata de daijoubu ka
to omoimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de shitsu
to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, shitsurei suru, kono rei to iu no
wa kore wa ii desu ne, kore wa polite to iu
imi desu.
Sore wo ushinau, to lose.
So shitsurei suru, kore, to be impolite.
De, shitsurei shimasu.
Ee sorekara, doumo shitsureishimashita.
Doumo sumimasen deshita.
Ano shitsurei shimasu tte iu no wa tatoeba
sensei no office ni hairu toki toka, ee sonna
toki ni mo tsukaimasu yo ne.
Sorekara shitsugyou suru, kore wa shigoto
to iu imi desu.
So shigoto wo, to lose.
So to become unemployed.
Sorekara, shitsubou suru, kore wa kibou no
bou, hope no imi desu.
So hope wo lose, shitsubou suru, to be disappointed.
Particle nan desu keredomo, ee, ano hito ni
wa shitsubou shimashita.
Ni to iu no wo, eeto tsukai masu.
Ato wa shippai suru, kore to fail.
Hantai wa ee, seikou suru, sakki benkyou shimashita.
Sorekara, eeto kore particle, shigoto ni shippai
shimashita.
Koko mo ni wo tsukaimasu.
Kunyomi desu keredomo, ushinau to iu yomikata
ga arimasu.
Ee, shigoto wo ushinatta, I lost a job.
Sorekara, taisetsu na hito wo ushinatta, I
lost an important person.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Ee, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desukeredo mo, imi wa to be
toka exist no imi desu.
De, eeto kono kanji no paato (part) daijoubu
desu yo ne, eeto kore ma, person, kono paato
(part) desu keredomo, person.
Sorekara, earth and suppose this is the heaven.
So people exist between heaven and earth to
iu no de, ma exist toka to be to iu imi desu.
Yomikata desu keredomo, onyomi de zai to iu
no ga arimasu.
Zaigaku suru, kore wa gakkou no gaku desu
yo ne, de to be enrolled.
Kore wa school no situation desu.
Sorekara, zaitaku suru, kore wa to be at home.
Sorekara sonzai suru, kore to exist.
Taizai suru to iu no de, to stay.
Ee, tatoeba, ee nandesuka, nihon ni taizai
shimasu.
Konna iikata wo shimasu.
Sorekara genzai, kore present.
Sorekara fuzai, kore wa inai to iu, kore negative
desu yo ne, desukara be absent.
Kunyomi nan desu keredomo, kore aru nan desu
ga, aru, iru, eeto ma kore wa hiragana de
mo, minna no baai daijoubu desu.
Hai.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa rice.
Sorekara, kono kanji wo tsukatte desu ne,
amerika (America) to iu imi mo arawashimasu.
De, ano, component nan desu keredomo, kore,
koko no bubun wa kore hachi.
Sorekara kore wa jyuu desu yo ne.
Soshite, kore hachi nan desu keredomo, ee
nihon de desu ne, sono, ano, in growing rice,
ee, we have to like take a lot of care so
hachi jyuu hachi kai no no nandesuka process
caring wo shinakucha ikenai to iu no de, kore
de hachi jyuu hachi, ma equal rice to iu.
Konna oboekata wo nihon jin no kodomo tachi
wa shiteimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, ee, kore onyomi
de bei toka mai to iu no ga arimasu.
Ee, kore beikoku, kore America to iu imi desu.
Soerkara, oobei, kono saishou no ou nan desu
keredomo, kore wa yooroppa (Europe).
Desu kara, oobei to iu no de, yooroppa (Europe)
to amerika (America).
Sorekara hokubei, kore wa kita desu yo ne,
so North America.
Nanbei, kore wa South America.
Nichibei to iu no de, nihon to america (America)
to iu imi desu.
De, kono mai to iu yomikata de, rice no imi
ga dedekimasu.
Tatoeba, genmai to iu no wa unpolished rice.
Sorekara, seimai to iu no ga polished rice
desu.
De, kunyomi no hou de, kome nan desu keredomo,
mo, kore wa daijoubu desu ne, kore wa rice
no imi desu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desukeredo mo, imi wa believe
toka trust, sorekara messeji (message) to
iu imi mo arimasu.
De, ee kono part, kore daijoubu desu ne, kore
person.
Sorekara, kono part, kore wa words toka, something
to do with saying nan desu keredomo, so a
person is believing of words of someone else,
ma kore de believe, trust to iu imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de shin,
ee, kunyomi wa arimasen.
De, tatoeba, shingou, desu ka, kore wa traffic
light desu.
Sorekara, jishin, self, kore ma trust, self
confidence desu yo ne.
Yoku ee, jishin ga arimasu, I'm confident
toka to iu kanji desu ne.
Sorekara, shinyou suru,
kore wa to believe.
Ee yoku kanojo no koto wo shinyou shite imasu,
I believe in her.
Sorekara, shinrai suru, to trust.
Ee, kanojo no koto wo shinrai shite imasu,
i trust in her toka to iu, ee, kore dochira
mo transitive desu.
Sorekara, henshin suru, kore to reply no imi
desu.
Hai.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa visitor,
sorekara customer toka, guest no imi ga arimasu.
De, ee kono ue no radical, kore wa daijoubu
desu ne, kore wa shape of a roof of a house,
ma house roof no imi desu.
Ee sorekara, kono shita no paato (part) nan
desu keredomo, kore imi toshite wa each to
iu imi ga arimasu.
So each person or everybody who comes to the
house you have to treat like a guest.
Ee, to iu no de, ma imi toshite wa guest toka
customer, visitor to iu imi desu.
Yomikata desu keredomo, onyomi de kyaku, kaku
to iu imi ga arimasu.
Kunyomi wa arimasen.
De, kyaku to iu no de, kore guest toka customer.
Yoku okyakusan to ii masu.
Sorekara kyaku seki, kore wa okyaku san to
tame no seki, seat to iu no de, seat.
Ano, toku ni theater nanka de yoku tsukawaremasu.
Sorekara raikyaku, ee okyaku san ga kita to
iu no de, visitor.
Sorekara, jyoukyaku, kore wa norimono ni noru
desu yo ne, so passenger.
Sorekara, kankoukyaku, kore wa tourist, kankou
suru, to tour no imi ga arimasu.
So kankyou kyaku, kore tourist.
Ato, na adjective de kyakkanteki na, kore
objective.
Sono hantai nan desukeredomo, ma shukanteki
na, kore subjective no kotoba mo arimasu.
Ee, dewa tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa to flow,
sorekara current, ee sorekara style no imi
ga arimasu.
De, ee, kono hidari no part, kore wa daijoubu
desu ne, kore water nan desu keredomo, kore
migi no part, kore by itself means like flowing.
So water is flowing to iu no de, flow.
Sorekara, current, kore wa ano water current
no koto nan desu keredomo.
Yomikata desu ga, ryuu toka ru ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, ryuukou suru, kore widespread.
Ee, konna sutairu ga ryuukou shiteimasu toka.
Ato, byouki nanka de, ma kaze ga ryuukou shiteiru
kara, kiotsukete kudasai.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Sorekara jouryuu to iu no de, upper stream
to iu imi mo arun desu keredomo, upper classes
to iu imi mo arimasu.
Ee, karyuu, kono hantai desu yo ne, downstream.
Mata wa, lower classes.
Context ni yotte kore wo handan shite kudasai.
De, jouryuukaikyuu, kaikyuu tte iu no wa,
hontoni classes nan desu keredomo, kono toki
ni wa hontoni upper classes.
Jouryuukaikyuu to karyuukaikyuu, konna tsukaikata
mo shimasu.
Ato, ichiryuu, kore wa top class, top notch
no imi desu.
Ichi ryuu no joyuu desu, actor, actress.
Sorekara, denryuu, kore wa ma current to iun
desu ga, electric current no imi desu.
Kunyomi nan desu keredomo, ee, intransitive
transitive no pair ga arimasu.
Intransitive nani nani ga nagareru.
Tatoeba, ee, denryuu ga nagareru.
Sorekara mizu ga nagareru, ee, sorekara transitive,
nani nani wo nagasu, ma kore wa to drain toka
run nan desu keredomo, denyuu wo nagashite
kudasai.
Denyuu kore ii desu ne, ano electric current,
wo nagashite kudasai, run the electricity
no you na kanji desu.
Sorekara mizu wo nagashite kudasai.
Kou iu tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Hai. Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa to acquire,
gain, profit no imi ga arimasu.
De, chotto kanji no component wo mite mimashou.
Ee, kono radical kore wa daijoubu desu ne,
kore to go to iu imi ga arimasu.
Ee, sorekara, kono migi gawa no, ee, shita
no
paato (part) nan desu keredomo, kore, kore
wa desu ne, a little toka short period of
time no imi ga arimasu.
Ee, sorekara, kore, ue no bubun, kore sunrise.
So in order to get something good, there is
a short period of time right after sunrise
so you must go that time to iu, sonna imi
desu.
Kore to acquire to iu imi desu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de toku
to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, toku na, kore, ee na adjective desu,
ee economical toka profitable.
Yoku tsukawareru no ga otoku na shoku hin,
ee to iimasu, ee gomenasai, shouhin, eeto,
product desu.
Sorekara, tokui na, kore benkyou shimashita
ne, be good at.
Sorekara, ee, sono hantai wa nigate na, be
poor at.
Ee, ato otokui san to iu no de, good customer.
Yoku kite kureru okyaku san to iu imi desu.
Sorekara, shotoku, kore wa income no imi ga
arimasu.
Ato, settokusuru, kore to persuade someone.
Tatoeba, ryoushin wo settoku shita.
Ee, sorekara, tanaka san ni daigaku iin ni
susumu you ni settoku shita.
I persuaded tanaka san to go to graduate school
to iu, konna tsukata wo shimasu.
Ato, shutoku suru to iu no wa, to learn, to
acquire.
Tatoeba, gaikokugo wo shuutoku suru no wa
muzukashii.
Sorekara kakutoku suru, kore wa to obtain,
to acquire.
Kunyomi desu keredomo, ee, eru, kore uru to
iu yomu hito mo irun desu keredomo, ma eru
kore de daijoubu desu.
Tatoeba, ee, sono chii wo eta, to gain, to
acquire no imi desu.
Shougakkin wo etta.
Sorekara, egatai, to iu kotoba, tsukaikata
ga arimasu.
Kore wa hard to get.
Tatoeba, kare no doi, ee, consent, kare no
doi wa egatai.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa to be
defeated to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, chotto paato (part) wo mitte ikimashou.
Ano kono component nan desu keredomo, I imagine
there’s a hand and some tool, and meaning
toshite wa ma hit lightly with a tool to iu.
De, hidari gawa, kono radical desu yo ne,
kore wa shell to iu imi desu.
So if you hit a shell lightly, it can be broken,
be defeated to iu imi desu.
De, onyomi nan desu keredomo, hai, to iu no
ga arimasu.
Ee shouhai, kore wa victory or defeat.
Ee, kore wa katsu to iu no de, victory.
Sorekara kore ga makeru to iu no de, defeat.
Sorekara, haisen, ee kore sensou no sen desu,
war, desu ga, so defeat.
Sorekara shippai suru, to fail, hantai wa
seikou suru.
Ee, kunyomi nan desu keredomo, yabu to iu
yomikata ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, ee, yabureru, ee, kore intransitive
desu.
Ee, nani nani nihon chiimu (team) ni yabureta.
Lost to the Japanese team.
Sono counterpart, transitive verb de wa, nani
nani wo yaburu, to defeat to iu.
Tatoeba, nihon chiimu (team) wo yabutta, to
defeat the Japanese team.
Sonna, ee konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa number
toka, count no imi ga arimasu.
Chotto component mite ikimashou.
Ee, kore, daijoubu desu ne, onna no hito no
onna desu.
Ee, sorekara, kore, ee koko no bubun, ee benkyou
shimashita kedo, kore rice no imi desu yo ne.
Sorekara, kono migi gawa, sakki benkyou shita,
kore, nanika, kono, hand with a tool.
So a woman is counting rice with some sort
of tool in hand to iu no de, ma number toka
count no imi ga arimasu.
De, onyomi de wa, suu, toka, su tte iu no
ga arun desu keredomo, tatoeba suugaku, kore
wa ma mathematics.
Sorekara, suuji, kore wa number.
Sorekara, sansuu, kore, arithmetic.
Tasuu, kore wa kazu ga ooi to iu no de, great
number, or majority.
Shousuu, kore wa kazu ga, number ga sukunai
to iu no de, few, minority.
Sorekara, odd number, even number to iu no
de, kisuu, guusuu to iu kotoba ga arimasu.
Sorekara ninzuu, kore wa hito no kazu.
Number of the people.
Ee, kunyomi de wa, kazu toka kazoeru, konna
yomikata wo shimasu.
Kazu kore wa mo number ii desu ka.
Sorekara kazoeru, kore wa transitive verb
desu, to count.
Tatoeba, kyaku no kazu wo kazoeru, to count
the number of the customers.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa to continue
to iu imi desu.
Ee component nan desu keredomo, ee, kono hidari
no radical, kore wa yarn toka thread no imi
ga arimasu.
Sorekara, kochira, migi gawa, kore wa to sell,
uru to iu imi nan desu keredomo, ma you need
to continue selling the thread to iu, ma kore
continue to iu imi desu.
Ee, onyomi nan desu keredomo, zoku.
Ee, tatoeba, keizoku suru, to continue.
Sorekara renzoku suru.
Kore wa to occur in succession.
Sorekara, setsuzoku suru, to connect.
Kunyomi de wa, tsuzuku, tsuzu to iu yomikata
ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, ee, kore intransitive nan desu keredomo,
tsuzuku, to continue.
Geemu (game) wa ima mo tsuzuite imasu.
Sorekara, transitive counter part de, tsuzukeru,
kore wa kono mama geemu (game) wo tsuzukete
kudasai, continue the game as is to iu kanji
desu.
Kore wa wo desu.
Kochira wa intransitive desu.
Sorekara, tetsuzuki to iu kotoba ga arimasu.
Kore procedure nan desu keredomo, yoku tsukau
no ga, nyuugaku tetsuzuki, so procedure for
entering school.
Sorekara, nyuukoku tetsuzuki, kuni e hairu tame
no procedure, tetsuzuki, to iu tsukaikata desu.
Hai. Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa to increase
no imi ga arimasu.
Ee, chotto component mite ikimashou.
Ee, kono component, kore ii desu ne, soil
no imi ga arimasu.
Doyoubi no do desu.
Ee, sorekara kono shita no part, kore wa sand.
Ee, so good soil and a lot of sun are necessary
in order to increase the growth of crops in
the rice field, kore rice field, soshite kore
ga crops.
Ee, de, zenbu de, ma, to increase to iu imi
ga arimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, zou, onyomi de.
Tatoeba, zouka suru, to increase.
Sorekara, zoudai suru, nani nani ga zoudai
suru, kore wa intransitive desu.
To increase in size.
Sorekara, zougen suru, ee, kore wa to increase
and decrease.
Sorekara, zouzeisuru, kore wa zeikin, taxes
to iu imi desu.
So to raise taxes.
Sorekara, kyuuzou suru.
Kore wa, kyuuni, rapidly, ni increase, to
increase rapidly.
Sorekara, baizou suru, kono bai tte iu no
wa double no imi ga arimasu.
So baizou suru, to double.
Tatoeba, ee, jinkou ga baizou shimashita to
iu.
Ato, kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, ee,
intransitive transitive no pair ga arimasu.
Ee, fueru, ee kore intransitive nan desu keredomo,
tatoeba, jinkou ga fueru.
The population increases.
Sorekara, fuyasu, kochira wa intransitive,
a sumimasen, transitive desu.
Increase something.
Tatoeba, gakusei suu wo fuyasu, ii desu ka.
Wo wo tsukatte kudasai.
Particle wo kiotsukete kudasai.
Hai. Ee, dewa ressun (lesson) 5 no saigo no kanji.
Kono kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji no imi desu keredomo, imi wa
hundred million to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, component nan desu keredomo, kono hidari
gawa kono radical daijoubu desu ne, kore person
toka people.
Sorekara migi gawa, kono paato (part) nan
desu keredomo, kore, imi, ma intention to
iu imi ga arimasu.
So person’s intention is worth hundred million,
to iu ma, hundred million to iu imi nan desu
keredomo.
Ee, onyomi de, oku to iu no ga arimasu.
Kunyomi wa arimasen.
Ichioku, ee kore de one hundred
million.
Tatoeba, ichioku en, one hundred million yen.
Sorekara, okumanchouja to iu kotoba ga arimasu.
Kore, billionaire desu.
Tatoeba, bill gates wa okumanchouja desu.
Ma konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.